i left my house at like 11 30 got here
at 11 45.
since when is the day after the fourth
uh a holiday
i don't know everyone has it off i was i
when i hit the road i'm like where the
[ __ ] is everybody
i think most corporate companies do have
that day off like my sister isn't
working but since when
i don't know is that a new thing maybe
maybe it's because the fourth fell
on a sunday people will give uh their
workers the monday off just because they
celebrate with their families
so they probably so it's a long weekend
yeah it might be one of those situations
where if it falls on a sunday they'll
give you the monday off
whereas everybody has been running hard
in the pango in the office because we
haven't been a pandemic the past
year at home
vegas was wild because of that what
vegas was wild because
literally lately you went to vegas yeah
i went to vegas
you guys be traveling man you and steven
yeah we went to go see
burr for my birthday on saturday how was
it it was fun he was so good have you
seen him before
i've seen not live i've seen his you see
him at the store or nothing no
have you been to the store i've been to
the store a few times but
uh not a bunch i don't know some people
haven't been there
and that i lost a grand on roulette i
lost so bad that every single one of the
dealers apologized to me because they
said it was statistically damn near
impossible
for me to lose that much money did you
bet one
hand like did you or were you like you
lost over a bunch of hands
a bunch of hands oh you didn't put like
uh so like i'll put it on the
i did that colors i did that a few times
when i needed to make my money back yeah
to try to stay in
but i would try to hit numbers i [ __ ]
up yeah and stevie wasn't gonna let me
leave vegas
unless i hit one of those numbers i hit
one and then i lost the rest
see i stay on black always yeah i was
bad black
i was bad black i do black and there's
basketball we don't recognize right
black
yeah i don't see color um only in
roulette
black all the way where did you guys
stay at
we stayed at cosmo because that's where
he was performing so it was nice
cosmo is really nice i think they opened
up a new one on the strip though it's
called resort world
[ __ ] yeah it's not as nice it's um
towards the wind like at the end of this
trip
oh yeah yeah they had a bunch of like
tick-tockers out that weekend djing and
stuff so it was just packed with like
young people and then old people trying
to
get out because of the pandemic yeah
stevie loves burr right and that's
what i left with 45 cents 45 cents 45
cents cash balance
hey sometimes it happens 999 and [ __ ]
yes yes 65 cents but it was fun it was
great
but you just shout out to people who
gave me that money on only fans for my
birthday yeah
how much did you they gave you some
extra money for you yeah somebody gave
me birthdays like
go gamble with them i'm so sorry i lost
i lost
all of it thank you though i knew johnny
i'm sorry i knew christian was lit i'm
[ __ ] yeah i was calling you
i knew you were lit on fourth of july
because he was sending me guest ideas
for finding the kid
you had to be drunk yeah yeah he was
hammered
i i said the same guy like seven times
gianni was like broke
on a group chat he's like dude how much
have you had to drink you've said that
several times though were you at a party
oh yeah i went to my buddy's house for a
while
yeah oh my god i don't remember like i
woke up i guess i sent some snapchats to
people i have no idea what the [ __ ] i
sent in them
um i'm just hoping i was clothed in it
so that's all i'm praying for
hammered yeah were you guys playing
drinking games or everyone so when i got
there we
like i had a couple drinks and then we
started playing uh stack cop
we played that like all day yeah i don't
know i'm
still like new at it like you get a cup
and you you take a drink then you try
and bounce the ping-pong ball in the cup
if you get in you pass it to the next
person and then the person
to like say cat had the drink next to me
she would try and get it in her coffee
before me and then she stacks it i have
to take a drink how about the old school
bear pop
yeah no beer pong was like about just
[ __ ] drink look at this i did i was
look at these hammered look at these
dorks
what smart ass university is this dog i
had no idea what i was doing it looks
straight
yeah it looks pretty easy to bounce it
in no [ __ ] drinking games
so you got hammered huh yeah yeah what'd
you do for the fourth gen
anything yeah i went to my buddy brian's
house in norco
we had like a a bunch of us knew each
other for like
just 20 years since high school so a
bunch of us just met up there
at the house i forget how old you are
over 20 years
over 20 years now it's jin's just older
dude
i don't know jake got a gift for 20
years i graduated 95
i was eight years old in 95. i was 12.
it's so trippy i'm looking at you guys i
don't feel that much different but no i
don't you guys were babies when i was
graduating high school
yeah she
it was a scary thing that was like the
first time i saw someone or heard about
someone that's a famous rock star
killing himself yeah yeah yeah you're a
little older
you don't look like i never think about
that no you don't
that's weird i don't know what what age
do they mistake you for
i don't get everything though i get
everything though but you never give up
no one's saying 20. no no no one's ever
saying 40 though right yesterday they
said i was 20.
not yesterday uh fourth of july the
saturday or at the party there was like
a white couple
they thought i was in my late 20s yeah
but there's a good lighting and
everything too i think
you know 30 so i can't see like 31
34 yeah thank you yeah you forget
you forget we just had i mean what are
you gonna do on the fourth there's no
like pop and fire
like when i was a kid it was lit we had
my dad take us to the fireworks stand
yeah we pick out black cats m80s all the
cool [ __ ]
it can't be you can't do it it's illegal
here yeah cause those fires those
[ __ ] trees especially uh out your way
oh yeah [ __ ] just the professional
fireworks those were popping all night
and then tiger for the first time he's
never had a reason be scared of like
hornets and bees and there are some in
the backyard
dude some hornet stung that kid twice
that [ __ ] satan's devil's [ __ ]
armies
lying to just oh man i've never heard
him scream out like oh dude
i don't think that feels good oh you
ever stood by anything like that a ton
it must have [ __ ] hurt the way he
cried out
i've been stunned by scorpion oh really
in arizona
yeah it was in my bed smaller [ __ ] it
got me uh it was probably like this
it got me uh right below my balls and
then on my calf
damn yeah got me twice it hurt like a
[ __ ] the one that woke me up was
the
the one on my calf i knew as soon as i
like that woke me up it
as soon as it happened i was i was like
i don't know 23. ah i knew exactly what
yeah
my whole leg was just [ __ ] shot the
whole day when was the last time we got
stung by
i'm terrified because a kid i get stung
so many times but you know when you're a
kid you
you make it so dramatic i can't remember
what it's like so i'm terrified of them
yeah terrified never i've never have you
ever seen
i've never been stung by anything and
though those hornot days are just
different like bees pollinate the world
we need them they make honey
or nates what are they here for you
you're just kidding
where the bees jump that hornet oh yeah
bruh
that's just insane they [ __ ] him up they
[ __ ] him up because it attacks one of
them
which like they set like they set it up
that way is it like a gang
war yeah i guess but one sacrificed his
body one second and then the rest
terrorism
like the whole fam we're barbecuing all
day there's music yeah everybody's
outside i'm like dude
you gotta go back outside he's like no i
need he always says i need space i'm not
going out there
you don't need space dude
i'm sick of this cruel world i'm like
what are you watching dude
where you come up with these random
cruel
time channels yeah you get stung by a
[ __ ] wasp dude
he's watching telenovela i know i'm like
i gotta get him back out there
so i go hold on dude i'm gonna go
outside let me see what i can do
so i come back in like dude talk to the
head uh hornet out there
we came to agreement they're not gonna
mess with you anymore he's like really
talk to him like yeah he's like
they speak english i'm like what dude
you're five just [ __ ] rolling he's
like
this i'm like no i i talked to him he's
like you talking to me i'm like yeah
tiger and then it goes down this deep
hole i'm like dude
just get outside for god's sake i don't
speak me for [ __ ] sake
get out there i love how kids just like
everything
everything's real how did you talk to
him like what do you mean how did i talk
to me like
do he speaks english like no they speak
spanish
like no he's [ __ ] speaking he goes
you speak b.o yeah
and he's like oh so what'd you say to
him like i said to him like leave us
alone
tiger's not a bad kid don't sting him
anymore and he agreed to it he's like
[Music]
that's what's funny about kids they ask
questions that you don't literally [ __ ]
no never because you're like oh yeah to
be yeah it's cool
and then he's like hit you with another
question in my head i was like yeah i'm
just
like
he's not gonna mess with anymore he did
go out there you wouldn't understand dog
yeah he did go out subtitles for that
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] terrifying i
remember my dad
this was so scared of bees i was like
seven and there's a beehive in our shed
where we used to live in aurora and he's
like oh here it
i'm sorry it was a [ __ ] hornet's like
nest
so if you know the bee spray doesn't
work on hornets
it doesn't work no they eat that [ __ ]
like it's [ __ ]
you know gatorade it doesn't work on
them my dad didn't know that gives me
the thing it was right spray them i'm
gonna go
over here and get some stuff so i'm like
cool i'm spraying
and they're like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah and they all come out sting me in
the neck
the back terrified puffed up huh
terrified
terrified and the the the hornets they
have like that dirt
um yeah right that adobe yeah they built
like uh
yeah yeah yeah it's a whole [ __ ]
two-level [ __ ]
condo yeah made out of dirt is that it
yeah it's almost like paper right
they're [ __ ] terrifying dude [ __ ]
them things though what are they here
for dude
i don't know besides to cause pain jim
find out what are hornets for
do we need hornets yeah yeah and those
black
black long juicy ones with the abs they
look like little helicopters
no that's a june bug no you never seen
that black coronate with the
abs a little bit of hair on them no
oh dude i'm thinking of junior help us
pollinate oh get the [ __ ] out of it
we have no figs no fig newtons okay i
can d
deal without fake newton's satan big
news like that though
hornets and pepper wasps prey on other
insects help keep pes
inspect or whatever man they're here for
population control
yeah all right they're [ __ ] but also
who who [ __ ]
when's the last time you had a fig
newton there's been a while that's a
good question
you like those [ __ ] yeah one's last time
you have here though with a nice cup
dark roast coffee a nice fig noodle
but they have raspberries they have that
weird like uh they have different
flavors though fig but i like the
raspberry
yeah they're [ __ ] nice hard pass
really hard well is the last time you
had one though
oh it's been years yeah what oh i'm
going to change my mind
i don't know you're older now well
you're probably drinking [ __ ]
it's like munchie food you gotta enjoy
it man
don't pull out my drinking days dog
several varieties
see they got the apple cinnamon fire
strawberry fire raspberry
mixed berry get the [ __ ] out of my face
whole grain
variety fat freak come on fat free what
are we doing
a fat free they have fat free big news
just [ __ ] eat it dude i remember we
bought those
i worked at a place called fedco for
lunch we would buy fig newton's fat free
and fat-free hot dogs and we thought
we're not going to gain weight and then
we learned later on okay there's sugar
carbohydrates yeah it's just no bad yeah
some fats healthy for you
so they thought they could get you with
the fat freak yeah back in the day
they're like yeah we'll hit you with
that fat free and then
was this when you were 300 uh that's
when i was getting a little bit lower
lower than 285 i was going to say that
everything was looking at honda i know
i felt free i was trying to learn i was
learning you didn't know
i didn't know now i learned nothing no
nothing nothing
all that fat free stuff like isn't like
it's bad right
calories calories and some fat and a lot
of fats good for you
uh well that's diet never mind what i
say you [ __ ] with diet coke
yeah that doesn't do it there's no
research shows that that
causes any harm people people beg to
differ
i mean but there's i'd love to see
evidence if if it was really harmful
then there'd be so many deaths
there's no real death you know how long
it's yeah it's been around forever
hot second yeah they do say like the
artificial sweetener can spike insulin
still because your body still
thinks it's sugar but there's no so like
if there's no evidence
there's like no actual like data that
shows that it's bad for you
i'll drink some [ __ ] diet coke i know
you will yeah you and stevie stay on
diet coke
love them i'll do it i'll do it
occasionally
is better for you though because it's
sweeter than stevia yep it's better than
the artificial sugar sure stevia mm-hmm
it's my favorite
i know my favorite those are the best
the purple one purple one's my favorite
yeah great purple and the green
sweet ones i like the fruity ones but
you like the sweet ones i don't like the
grape one
i like the root beer one oh would you
like a [ __ ] fig newton i know
please don't get down on grape zebia dog
no hard pass on the grape anything
but uh yeah i like i like the uh cream
soda one i like the yellow one and the
brown one
you like that kind of stuff i don't do
the uh the xevia uh
coca-cola one oh those aren't bad the
blue is the light the blue
the blue and there's no caffeine in them
yeah those are terrific
oh you know what we did last night
because it was we're on or on season
three episode one of games of thrones we
had uh we were betty hannas
what's that song at benihana's benihana
is just fried rice isn't it
no i don't how dare you the hibachi
where it's like you get cut
or they cook in front of you yeah but
they just you they
postmates they're dropping off it comes
in this [ __ ] so what do you order
what are you yeah benihana's like i've
never had hobbies they're fillet like
you can get the
flaming young the shrimp then comes the
spicy
fried rice it's okay so it's just
i don't [ __ ] with the noodles it's
bougie chinese food that's it i don't
know japanese
japanese but i mean nice when they cook
it in front of you the fried rice with
the butter and everything and the onions
it just smells so good and it tastes so
good when you eat it right there as as a
30
mid 30s year old man when you go there
and the yeah i
feel bad for the guy who's like oh here
we go
they have like the onion and they put
the flame out it's a volcano
do you want the stupid performance or
not because everyone if if there's not a
kid at the table it's like
what are you doing yeah it's a
definitely flick a [ __ ] shrimp in
your hat
but it is cool when you watch it though
ah man the first couple times the main
reason why you go to benihana i don't
know anyone who actually goes in just
for food really
i imagine i imagine i i agree with you i
imagine people go for the performance
yeah
that's what i imagine really the food's
pretty cool
right he'll he'll pop it up flick it in
your mouth yeah they do they do it in
your mouth sometimes
yeah yeah i wanna i want an option where
i don't have any of that [ __ ]
you know they use 150 i'm so excited now
did you know that for what
for i don't know they use 151 to clean
it or something i don't know something
you can get they they uh oh yeah you get
the fire yeah that's why mm-hmm
and then he goes ah 151 no uh
what's his name dj aoki his dad
created
[Music]
yep he has one in his backyard damn yep
that guy's legit that's where his family
made their money it was benihana
that place is great yeah that place is
[ __ ] great
i don't know a single asian person who's
ever been to benihana and went back for
food that's the reason why i just think
it's like a touristy attraction
for people like if you don't like asian
food that's like probably the best
introduction to it interesting i would
say korean barbecue
no that would be barbecue is kind of
like the same thing it's kind of
performative
it's not really and it's kind of like
basically it's food you know just but
that
came out way way for uh before yeah
before i even started going to korean
barbecue but i would go benny hannah
korean barbecue yeah for sure now 100
you know my mom worked at benihana for
like over
20 years i think she was retired she's
she retired as a waitress how do you
feel about hating on it
yeah that's fine that's why you know
your mom's life did they give your mom
any benefits
no i don't i don't know betty i just
heard a bunch she she served kobe a lot
kobe had his own table in there toby
right right yeah he loves going there
like yeah of course he's the [ __ ] mom
yeah his own section he used to always
go there with his wife and his kids
that's great
kids love it yeah the newport beach one
yeah because it's lit
is that where your mom worked she
retired there yeah oh
that's she was a waitress for a very
long time yeah server am like a cashier
person for
the waitress is there it's like you get
the drinks that's about it
well they have to do the food stuff i
mean there's also foods that you can
order from the kitchen as well
like sushi stuff that they don't they
don't have sushi now
they have sushi sushi yeah i think they
have that sushi for a while
cat you and stephen you guys are doing
all this [ __ ] all the time
i've never had it's actually in my life
that was like last night yeah we were at
castles
yeah i got some money just thriving
shit's changing passed away every night
did you guys have a good view
yeah we had a good view stevie tried to
do like a fourth of july brunch for my
birthday but then
what was your name uh the third on
saturday [ __ ] happy birthday
thanks hey hey hey [ __ ] me
happy birthday man i don't know anybody
thank you you didn't say it but you guys
both
also knew because stevie posted it
you're not on social media that doesn't
yeah but i'm pretty good i was like wait
it's not today that's why i said wait
yeah true you texted me a day before
that's why you went to vegas for your
birthday yeah
but uh we were supposed to go to brunch
with my sister stevie and i and last
minute stevie made a joke like oh we
should invite justin because justin's
been trying to hit on my sister
for you for like a year now for like
almost a year yeah you like
the ass i told them oh no i don't think
it's that i just don't think they're
like compatible personality-wise makes
sense i don't know your sister but yeah
but yeah he brought it up a few days
before as a joke like oh wouldn't it be
funny if we just snuck justin in
and my sister and i laughed like oh
that'd be funny but no let's just keep a
three of us
and last minute we went and we got to
our booth there were four plates we're
like huh that's weird whatever
we sat down like 30 minutes it just came
late you
showed up 30 minutes late this was your
shot dude
he showed them 30 minutes late and my
sister and i are lucky i am so confused
like oh are you here with another group
of friends
yeah what are you doing oh yeah look at
stevie he's just laughing his
ass off he posted a picture of him at
castaway just him by
by himself yeah on his instagram
because we were castaway they were
taking uh photos because it's such a
pretty spot
and i took this photo for him he asked
my sister to get in a photo and my
sister said no
oh man but justin's into that he's like
this only makes me want her more
who got it to go play for him damn he
wore a t-shirt and shorts
yep yeah damn justin
was this probably casual it wasn't a
pool party ever you've been a castaway
they didn't know casually
it was a little different it was for
brunch so everyone was kind of dressed
uh more casually
the you know when we'd go there and they
would get like they'd give us like cool
[ __ ] all the time
yeah because that manager he left he
went to miami really we i
when my dad was in town we went there
not the same service
service was bad oh i forgot my girl's
food we all finished then they brought
her food out
i don't know if it would go back and
that was my spot i don't like that place
this is my spot it's not the same i know
their key lamp is [ __ ] good though
it's fire it's so good uh i don't
remember if i had it oh how about i know
it's a current member i'll talk about it
now how about that rick and morty
[ __ ] wendy's all right kids let's
take a little break from the
chat with the crew because ufc 264
is this saturday and we will be doing a
live calabasas fight companion with
myself
bradley martin freaking josh thompson
and cody garbrandt watch it live on the
thick boy youtube channel
chime in with your boys have fun with us
watch the fights and also
bet and make bank on the fights with my
friends at draftkings ufc 264
is here and draftkings got you guys
a great deal hear this draftkings is
offering 264 to 1 odds on a knockout in
the first round
during saturday's main event dustin
poirier vs conor mcgregor if the rubber
match ends in a first round knockout you
walk away with cash
just pick the main event fighter you
will you think will win by first round
uh knockout and draftking sportsbook
will give you 264 to one
odds on that fighter that's right bet
one dollar mcgregor poirier
to win by first round knockout and you
win 264
dollars you can also make bank and boost
the odds by doing my three fighter
parlay
if you bet on conor mcgregor wonder boy
thompson
and tia tuavasa
tai to avasta if you bet on all three of
them to win
it boosts your odds all three have to
win in order for you to make bank bro
there's no better way to put your mma
knowledge to the test than to put your
money where your mouth is with draftking
sportsbook
if you want to bet on my parlay go to
draftkings click on a little tab
at the top you'll see the brennan shop
boost odds and you can pick those three
fighters to win
don't worry if you're not into mma
because you're into other stuff which i
don't agree with
draftking sportsbook offers great odds
and promotions on
nba nhl so much more baseball we got it
all man draftkings are safe secure
reliable
so you can deposit and withdraw your
funds when you want download the
top-rated draftking sportsbook app now
use promo code fighter
when you sign up to turn one dollar into
264 dollars when you bet on the main
event fire
to win by first round knockout place
your bet and watch the fist fly
this weekend that's coach fighter turn
one dollar into 264 dollars
only at draftking sportsbook or if you
want to do the three fighter parlay
click on the branch job
boost tab and you can win
buckaroos must be 20 and older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only restrict supply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or
indiana 1 809 with it oh how about i
know it's a current member i'll talk
about it now how about that rick and
morty [ __ ] wendy's
so rick and morty uh converted a wendy's
in the whole rick and morty thing
so i think it's called morty's now it's
called more well it's it's
kind of close to my house things it's
closer to you i think it's like in the
middle of us
look up where it's at panorama panorama
i don't know
which location in panorama it is though
it just says
because they have like this cool
drive-through you go through it's like a
whole rick and morty yeah they put like
a rick and morty
drive-through area like those old lcd
screens
the christmas drive-throughs do you
remember they were doing that during the
pandemic
during halloween yeah yeah so the oh
they
it's uh rick and morty themed yeah look
it looks dope they have like a
pickle rick uh frosty
i think it is it's green so that might
be an issue but
see it's through oh that's dope i think
it ends
yeah it like says morty's oh it's just
only for a limited time oh only for two
days
no uh a weekend of june 18th through two
but if you scroll down
scroll down to you passed ready i think
it said it goes to august 22nd
see look that that uh that frosty like
suspect green but
it really does look suspect yeah what's
on top of it graham crackers
keep scrolling down 10.
how dope is that that is dope
oh look what they did to windy hell yeah
made it morty keep going chin i'm pretty
right because i want to take tigers
there see look at that [ __ ] that's cool
whoa keep going this is out here
yeah i think it's the only one
how long go in through the mouth oh
[ __ ] coco when he's also released two
limited edition drinks available through
august 22nd god damn it i can't drive
all the way there to get a [ __ ] diet
coke
god damn it past this box
oh that's pretty dope though that is
really tight about it
god damn it did you already tell you're
taking them
yes oh man i guess i said august 22nd i
gotta make some [ __ ] up
tell them the bees changing i'm like i
talked to the bees man
wait that show a little little extreme
for the younger audience
can be can be kind of like when morty
has sex with this
um robot they're [ __ ] in the yeah
well yeah he has they like the family's
eating breakfast and you hear just the
bed going
and he comes down he's like yeah you
know we're doing a lot of homework
up there and he's like all sweating in
his underwear and he drinks orange juice
and goes back
up but then she gets pregnant he has to
raise the baby
there's some dicey stuff some diced
stuff for sure
best cartoon ever though yeah [ __ ] with
it or not no i i
dude it's so hard for me to watch tv why
i just can't do it i can't find myself
to sit there and watch tv
really i feel like i'm stuck huh yeah
i just can't watch tv you don't watch
any tv not anymore not really i haven't
watched tv in a month just sit in
silence
yeah we'll read or journal or your
journal should go home and read and
journal
yeah are you from the [ __ ] 1910.
i'm a feather pen from 19 days
you have a cap you put it back today on
the podcast yeah
but white mike watches movies and [ __ ]
right yeah he does
so you just you'll see the tv and just
be like my room i have a tv reading i
have a tv in my room we have
one in the living room and then he has
uh one of his room but
yeah i just [ __ ] how do you get your
news and [ __ ] i don't
you don't to be fair he doesn't really
know anything when he comes in
yeah yeah yeah you say some [ __ ] i'll be
like
he's like there's a pandemic i've been
journaling all day
yeah i don't know you just journal a lot
yeah
that's cool oh how was boston didn't you
just go
i love boston i don't know why you had a
negative
connotation with boston that was some
people with some shitty no people in
here
you you read yelp no it wasn't a yell
review i'm just saying you say you won't
watch tv but you read yelp reviews
no boston's one of the best cities in
the east coast i think it's beautiful
there
i love the way the houses are old school
old green oh yeah
i liked it a lot where'd you invite go
to salvi where'd you go
i was in uh dorchester
dorchester and what were you doing out
there i was just going out there with my
buddies van they were uh
playing a show at that uh the house of
blues in boston
which is huge how big big it looked big
yeah it's like
i think if it's 2400 oh huge huge yeah
but they bring real bands in there yeah
now did you sing because you sent me a
video of all white guys singing
white guys i told you don't ever video
that you're not singing it don't see me
a bunch of white guys sing it yeah i
took a picture right by that fenway park
really the great monster yeah i think
it's on my ig story
i can't believe you flew while you were
there just you got the show was friday
night
yeah the show was friday you flew
thursday show friday
out saturday long ways to go oh my god
bro that early and
we flew out um back early um
did i post it
conversations oh no i didn't there you
guys are yeah
were you able to sing or no no i didn't
sing with this one it was like a
it was a who's that kind of emotional
show
oh that's why that's toby's uh wife
okay she drives that old school uh oh
that's dope
pontiac so yeah i mean you don't have to
watch my stories but you can see brendan
spotted me on this next one
335. one more one more could have done
250.
i mean 350. no too easy
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
why was it uh a big deal to go after
yeah uh uh this
uh uh bass player from this band called
bane hardcore band
bane yeah he's a reference to the batman
band i wonder
i don't know for sure for sure probably
but the bass player had passed away of
cancer and it was like a tribute show he
wanted to see these bands that's cool
coming together but unfortunately
he didn't make it to see the bands uh
perform but they
still did the show and did you know him
no i didn't know him like personally or
anything like that
just so but it was it was fun i mean
boston is just
it's just so i don't know it's something
electric it turns into the purge after
midnight like i do with wilbur and you
get
done around 12 31 you walk outside it's
the purge
oh really on a swivel sir oh damn yeah
we pretty much like
did the show gotten the the guy in the
band uh the van
uh and you know peaced out or whatever
did you guys
where did you guys stay in a hotel or
airbnb airbnb the houses are
that's what i'm saying i like the homes
there that's great they're cool looking
the problem with boston well they have
laugh boston that's like the main club
there that's what everyone says either
you laugh boston or you do
the wilbur problem with the wilbur
unless you're a big big boy you can do
two shows
friday two shows saturday i can't i can
do one and one yeah but you're not
getting full weekends there
yeah it's tough i would love wait i'd
love to do a full weekend not two in one
night
yeah i can't do two one night yeah it's
tough yeah
because that you look at like almost
three thousand tickets what does it look
like i see a picture of it the wilbur
uber's great
two years ago because of the pandemic
and rogan opened for me
oh he did yeah oh he said is that when
he lit up that heckler yeah
he had a scarf that's beautiful yeah
wilbur's iconic man
damn a bunch of people shot special out
of wilbert yeah wilbur's great
but yeah how many seats in that
[ __ ] so i mean around 1400 by
right right right over a thousand that's
the only that oh that's the owner yeah
that's amazing
just kidding they won't have me back
what's so funny is every single one of
us we're looking at i know we weren't i
mean
that's why we left he's like yeah that's
what we laughed it's not a great picture
um yeah it looks nice inside yeah but
it's dope man
i like i like that the old school
theater oh i love it
how long has it been there does it go
far back
i'm sure they have a lot of like old old
wilbur's legendary
yeah but but again i'd rather do i know
it's it's it's weird ringo fear the club
but i'd rather do a thursday friday set
at laugh boston
so that i can hang out and [ __ ] bo i
love boston dude yeah
it's something right name i wish i wish
i could have done a lot more there
which i i mean i can't wait to go back
there was originally open in 1914.
1914 damn old school
history history yeah it's a big boy
theater great place though
and then crowds are great as far as like
uh comedy goes great
some of the best i felt i don't know
like i just felt even like at this show
like the
any of those these girls like billy's
great boston's great austin new york's a
monster
that's about it yes i haven't been in
new york yet
haven't done staying up in new york i've
never been to new york oh damn
i think we're there in december welcome
to new york
it's been waiting you know that's
gotham right gotham gotham bathroom
comic club oh [ __ ] yeah god that's where
sebastian came up at
that club yep damn a lot of it they got
those old-school gotham videos online
too
yeah there's a yeah it's a great club
gotham's dope
yeah gotham was it yeah there's i mean
there's a milling place performing
any plans for europe europe's tough
because uh i got offers in europe and
australia it's just tough because
europe's
like uk shut the [ __ ] down right now
dude yeah
the uk still shut up oh yeah england's
yeah i don't think they're allowing
people out
like they're not like letting in and out
yes they're pretty locked down look at
that confirmed chin
is it because of that new variant the
[ __ ] delta uh
entire europe or just uh london or
something like that uh europe travel
restrictions someone said is europe a
country that's one of the top searches
damn somebody's
somebody stupid
europe has finally swung open stores to
american tourists first time since march
you will need to do more planning
since rules can vary country country if
you don't usually
buy travel insurance you might want to
consider
scroll down uh what's it say for that
the band
both united states and europe you have
active trial bans barn citizens from
entering the us drop in
lifted march 13th all right here's the
thing though it's lifted do you really
want to go tor out there right now and
risk then are they down to
gather in large groups you know what i'm
saying like it's not ideal
does it say lifted or it doesn't say
lifted
this is not that doesn't have to be old
wait hasn't soccer been going on
out there yeah and england's kicking ass
but this stadium is not in full capacity
it's pretty lit out there
yeah it looks like it's open but it's
just tough
so i'm bryan's there right now yeah uh
but uh so performing there they
they catch all the catch all the
references you wouldn't think they would
but they listen to the podcast like i
was worried about australia
dublin england i did manchester
liverpool all over manchester
yep and i was so worried they wouldn't
get the reference but they get it it was
lit because they listened to the phrase
it was amazing it was insane i saw that
little that that
does not feel ten years ago i know it
feels so long you me and jay went out
there
it was incredible i had no opener i know
yeah and it was an
enormous theater so yeah just myself and
chin like all right everybody
chewing on the bike you know him as my
boss
he's reading your hair you're looking
for brendan's job
and i'd come in the back like dude quit
saying i'm your boss
i just started oh no
but i literally just never have a ton of
energy bike all right everybody
you know him as my boss
but we did that in australia
no opener just me just headlining fresh
out the gate
ireland too nuts yeah wow
but they're waiting australia and oh
yeah i went everywhere yeah yeah yeah
yeah i want all those places new zealand
too
just me and jim went to australia just
me and chin and i barely started i
barely started so we started we were
just kind of like we didn't know
then we're like eating meals i know it
was like a weird blind date
jim was eating like this weird sushi
from the market i'm like oh this guy's
weird man
who the [ __ ] did i hire i know me and
trina had fun it was just it's just too
brand new to go on a
cross-country trip together yeah it was
just too brand new cross country you
mean [ __ ] we went across the world i
know i'm married at first sight
you and you made it yeah it was 90 day
fiance me and chance
when jay came out the other way
[Laughter]
yeah and jay gets along with everyone so
jay was like the third that was like the
thing that made it
super fun because i now there's someone
else in there yeah it wasn't like uh
just too often so
jay's different than me jay likes to
like explore i don't like
that yeah explore and walk and chill
like just chill and i'll find one good
restaurant coffee shop and just
go that'll be that'll be the thing jay
wants to [ __ ] see the family jewels
and yeah [ __ ] walk through all the
castles i'm like
dude was it his idea for us to go see
the oklahoma city
memorial that was mine because i was
reading all the [ __ ] about it oh god but
he wanted to see that too yeah he
doesn't want to see like the weirdest
[ __ ] where you're like all right man
that was a mistake that's right doesn't
it feel like 10 years ago it does and
when one's not going to happen again
later this year maybe not this year next
year next 2022 next year europe
because you don't want to do europe
australia the same year that's just too
much travel
so you do europe 2022 australia 2023.
yeah you made like a because australia
is far a video clip
of you in ireland i think oh yeah though
they did yeah but i thought who did you
like after you feel great yeah he was
awesome he was a super fan
so sick yeah oh so where do those live
are they i'm finding the kid
i don't even know they are yeah they are
yeah
i've made like little instagram ones i'm
not sure if that's on the youtube
channel but the main one the dublin one
yeah that's on fire in the kid yeah
we probably we probably fly out peter
and kyle this time
yeah hello peter yeah damn
that'd be sick that would be sick as
long as you got manchester on there
yeah yeah i'm all for it yeah we didn't
get to see too much i'll i'll stop
everything to go to manchester
do you know why christian play that [ __ ]
chin
oasis
this is my thing with this is he's like
i thought he caught his feet though good
i'm like yeah but he kind of said what
[Music]
chin looks the exact same exact same
thing insane
that's so beautiful oh dublin was so
amazing dude
we walked across that bridge too
[Music]
any place i've been to for sure i mean
australia too but it's like neck and
neck dublin is my favorite it's your
sugar club
just all white
and just crazy packed everything was
always crazy it was like in the middle
of the day
you know we did one like because i i did
four shows in one day two o'clock show
what's up
like noonish too is that a connor shirt
yeah it says 4901
it was before the floyd fight
[Music]
oh that's a cool setup yeah it's great
i wish clubs were like that tim dillon
all right
and that was our personal bar though we
just kept pouring constant guinness i
kept drinking guinness
like nonsense man i loved me some
goodness
oh yeah yeah out there it hits different
yeah it probably does and then if you
want to mix it up you can put a little
uh
current in it where it's like this berry
like syrup
they say it's for chicks i don't give a
[ __ ] you ever done the snake bite where
it's like they mix the cider and the
guinness
is it it's uh yellow and black yeah yeah
you ever done that well
there's black and tan right that's a
beard oh maybe that's what it's called
yeah
black and tan but it's not cider it's uh
like the mix like a beer
and then uh then get us that's a snake
bite
oh it's called a snake bite no i just i
just typed in that so black currant
cordial
or a diesel yeah oh i'll just go hey can
i get a
this beer inside it that's it i don't
want cider oh it's beer
the guinness you can't tell though i
mean it looks a little purple if there's
light on it but
but what what's in the club half bear
half guinness
like half of the guinness stuff didn't
you and jay go to the guinness [ __ ]
factory
one of them we did we we became
certified guinness poor's
damn you get a little certificate
everything really did you guys go to
jameson too
uh i don't think jameson where was i
when you're doing that you're probably
just chilling you had a lot of yeah
prep to do oh that's right oh press and
stuff yeah
yeah and then once brennan and me and
jay we went to a bar
to drink with uh guinness with current
they wrote an article about about it at
like two days afterwards remember yeah
oh
you're being there yeah yeah drinking
black with black currant because i guess
it's like this
it's like girly thing or something it's
like going like a tropical drink at a
bar now with like like a sex life
you wrote a freaking article about it
but then but then uh izzy
mean him had that weird tip where people
thought i was talking [ __ ] about him
and then me and him became cool again
because he went to dublin
he was at a bar and some dude was like
oh you're something like you're ordering
the bread and chop drink
and he was like what's that he's like
the current you're drinking that's what
shop drank when he said
and so he sent me a video like hey man
apparently this is your thing i was like
yeah
yeah i love that's my favorite because
what they just drink the guinness
straight
that's like the [ __ ] we were drinking
it straight and then then i think the
bartender was like you want something he
didn't say curry said something i was
like
and i like panic because you know i
don't yeah you don't know i was like
yeah put that [ __ ] in there
and you know so this is fantastic
but it tasted really good really good
dude the best drink i've ever had
i know the people in dublin watch right
like gotcha i know they're like i don't
care
it is fantastic drink that [ __ ] drink
oh it was nice
dublin's the only place i've been
outside in america where i felt like i
was in a different country
australia is la but cleaner england
is new york but different dublin you
felt like for sure really you're on like
you're doing a show for games of thrones
it was [ __ ] crazy yeah we're in new
zealand yeah
it's beautiful i feel that way in some
parts of montreal
yeah there's some like older like
there's this like i've been on my
journey to
and there's like you've been in a part
where it's like super old buildings
mm-hmm all of it's montreal's older city
yeah
i felt i felt like it there oh you know
where i'm going i want to go on vacation
at cape cod
cape cod no one ever talks about it i
was looking up yesterday i
couldn't sleep looked it up is it have
you been there um no
it's overrated i never had any desire
but you've never been
because i grew i know what it is i know
i know cape cod i know people who go and
they always tell me it's
yeah it's nice yeah but is it like
college kids looking to [ __ ]
get on grindr where the [ __ ] it is like
man out of college kids get on grindr
and [ __ ] that's driving sound
that's probably not someone get on
ground but if i could get like a dope
airbnb i found a really cool hotel there
is that
it'd be cool to go but like i mean like
it just never you gotta fly into boston
how far
drives it from boston ah
yeah yeah no shootings yep martha's
vineyard huh
yeah guys you know with some i look at
real estate all the time i was on zillow
looking at the houses off uh
cape cod jesus christ dude insane yeah
30
20 like 20 30 million dollars it's
really bougie over there
but martha's vineyard is even more yeah
yeah everyone's wearing vineyard vines
on mars oh hell yeah
do you a lot of what you said about
ireland
sweater over and just
yeah that's gonna be you dawg that's
what i want yeah you want that one
your pants end like a warmer a2 high up
real white calves yeah [ __ ] yeah i have
a little sunscreen
just on your nose bucket hat hard pass
is that like an east coast thing where
they were the hats higher what do you
mean
like you wear your hat higher that like
you don't wear it all the way down you
personally dressed in like turtle from
entourage or
uh no i just like to match yeah wow
what's going on is hockey is it over or
uh tampa bay might win the stanley cup
tonight they're about to sweep uh
montreal the series is three nothing i
can tell you really don't give a [ __ ]
about hockey is tampa bay
like it's not a huge market in florida
is it they are huge
because they're good this year yeah i
know they won last year so now they're
all about them
they're well they've always been like
they've been like a good team for the
past couple of years they've been up and
coming
hot tampa's on real hockey you know what
that makes that makes sense because a
lot of people
you know how they move from like jerseys
are dope and come down to like the
warmer weather
yeah that probably makes sense as to why
it's probably lit there for the panthers
have a wild fan base too yeah like you
just yeah
florida panthers that's right yeah
everybody on them we have a hockey team
in arizona
coyotes i also my friend plays uh connor
garland's a good friend of mine he plays
for their conor garland is a good friend
of yours yeah you have no idea
hey didn't gretsky play for the coyotes
for a hot second
we had stretchy no i think he played for
the kings i know he played for the kings
i don't think obviously the oilers i
thought he played like did
one year with the coyotes bring that
[ __ ] up jen i don't know
i should know this oh uh b who
who you got down the franchise
was he a coach or so he did something
for them
departure from coaching coach he stepped
down i knew he had something to do with
them
weird how my brain remembers that um
because i don't give a [ __ ]
i think you do a little bit a little i
mean i like wayne gretzky dude
he's trying to be nice to you no no no i
like wayne gretzky like when i did shows
in edmonton and
uh one of the people that run the oilers
like whole [ __ ] gave us like all access
and we got to watch them practice and
stuff and i said who's their stud
i mean david or dry side of which one
the young kid for the oilers
the captain yeah like david we saw
mcdavid i didn't realize he was like
he's like the guy nicest guy nicest kid
i've ever got he's good
watching him skate me and my brother
holy [ __ ] fastest nhl player in the
league
such a stuff is this the one that would
get a lot of fights no no he will never
fight no he scores goals
was there someone on the orders there
was like a beast talking about mark
messier
is that who the guy was so old school
and i doubt you you think of cassian
i only remember that because josh potter
we brought it up when josh potter was
here he said this guy would just
mark messi was a pretty badass on them
but he's not really like uh
cassian plays now he's a fighter he
plays for the oilers casting
cassie i don't know
have you ever have you seen that doc on
the the the
fighters in the nhl yeah they all have
like ptsd
and i can't stand it they're basically
all happy gilmore
like they don't have the skills like
score goals so eventually everybody
wants to be winning gretzky
and as they come up through the ranks
the coach like hey dude
you're never going to be wayne gretzky
why don't you just help us out and fight
that guy
that was what that was my fault
their position their job they're the
enforcers so they're not the best like
with the handles and the puck and doing
all that [ __ ] so i knew i was like that
when i was young
everyone my age was looking up to be
wayne gretzky i was hooking up to be
million lucci who was like a fighter in
the nhl i was like like i know i'll
never [ __ ] be wayne gretzky or even
half the skill like even a quarter of
the skill wing rescue had so
i'll just [ __ ] fight you a little
ball of energy if it was the only way i
could get to where i wanted to go
those guys are but on the documentary
just the the trauma and the stress they
have
oh damn because you're gonna be you
could not play like the game at all and
then like hey
go [ __ ] this guy up in the guys there's
uh nathan gerby he was
five he's my height in the nhl and
there's a photo with him
and zadino chara who's six seven one of
the tallest people in the nhl
they're fighting i don't know if they're
finding the picture but it's
like they have fought before it and it's
insane but they're talking about how
those enforcers like the night before
like you know it seemed like ufc you
know you're
gonna fight tomorrow that's your job so
they're stressed so they they have to
pick the fight
well it's like it's part of the game or
yeah like it's it's all it's like
it's close it's all strategy yeah like
if the
you know it's a shift like the momentum
or yeah if you're down someone takes a
shot at
like the star like mcdavid they take a
shot at him
then you're going to [ __ ] that guy when
does when do the revs
stop it when they fall to the ground
yeah so what like if that one so if the
fight doesn't go to the ground again if
they just like
they throw punches and then they let
them tire out like they'll be all
hanging up and then the refs will step
in after yeah sometimes they'll stop the
fight from even happening which
i'm not a fan of i don't i'm going away
a little more from fighting
i know it's unlucky dude but there's
there was there was a
series the washington capitals played
the rangers there was
six fights within the first two minutes
of the game
sometimes they'll knock each other out
yes
uh a young kid knocked the kid clean out
it was in it was wild
look at that guy okay who's that guy
twist
no that's don fry on skates
you don't know that guy no i wasn't i'm
not a canadian's fan
oh god you were ballsy and hockey though
i know i know i'm trying to imagine you
spit out the wrong names
it might as well be [ __ ] portrait
george perros okay god he looks sweet
this face looks best though that guy
right there go
uh to the left uh up
one right there to the right to the
right that guy is one of the best
fighters in the league
the guy in the white ron cook uh uh tom
wilson
who's he played for capitals he's the
reason why there was like eight like six
fights in the uh first two minutes of
the game against the rangers it was just
all hell broke loose it's crazy you know
how they talk about like greatest of all
time like jordan or something like that
look at wayne gretzky's stats like as
far as dominating the sport no one's
going there
no one's even close ovechkin's close to
beating his all-time goal record
yeah but he's played longer right no
really i don't think so no
you look at how dominant wayne gretzky
was even at like 17.
all right he's just kicking ass he'll
never be
canada he's originally from canada i
believe yeah he's from yeah he's as
canadian as he gets
um you ever seen his daughter no
what'd she look like that could have
gone one of two ways dime piece die
piece
does not look like her dad with a long
nose
there she is yeah she's a golfer
beautiful yeah super dime piece she's
married to a golfer oh she's
she's married to the golfer damn
there's a girlfriend girl calm down
dustin johnson
yeah he's number one in the world for a
while oh b who do you got
sons are uh bucks hoping suns
that's who you're going for yeah yeah
hard in the paint form i'm so dude have
you seen their jers their city jerseys
are so sick
which is is that the black it's and it's
like kind of like tide island it has the
phoenix on it's so sick you like that
one you're gonna get you one
i don't know yeah i don't know i feel
weird wearing another grown men's
jerseys
it is awkward i had a curry jersey
for a second steph curry what the [ __ ] i
only like wearing the older play shirts
it was a birthday gift like i have like
a sean cam
i have a vince carter yeah because they
don't play anymore and then the jerseys
i have that
are like current there's no numbers or
there's no numbers no name on it
yeah in order they'll put your name on
it yeah but if if they're out of the
game that makes sense
yeah like you rocked the german and i'm
doing that spurs uh that 18t
bud light venue you're like oh cause
connect the spurs they make you
authentic jersey
or they're like do you want a david
robinson like i don't know none of those
guys i would just put my name on the
back
i don't want anybody man did you [ __ ]
with anyone from the spurs though
dennis rodman oh that'd be hard he was
a number 10 jersey how did you do the
spurs that was after
him and the bulls you should go at it
and then jordan that was when he was on
the pistons
and also the spurs he was a knight oh
really the nightmare that's when his
hair was all colored and he's like crazy
he's a beast
he's [ __ ] insane how long do we
pretend david robinson was
on all the internet's rodman david
robinson was on winstrol like a
[ __ ] bring up his physique chin
when they had the twin towers shout twin
towers
when they had tim duncan when they had
tim duncan and
[ __ ] david robinson dude look how
jacked
[ __ ] tell me that's not winstrol son
nah that's natty yeah that's all natty
she's go to that picture to the bottom
left chin uh
look how much more jacked he is than tim
duncan no
go up oh my god look at that one down
there look at that trading card okay
yeah go to the training card
come on daddy here's my dad's favorite
player because he played at navy
look at that oh my god how long do you
want to pretend
carl malone was jack sitting shoulders
are just [ __ ] you know what bumped
you up at carmelo
malone's just big dude car malone you
realized how shitty of a father he was
you're like oh god
he had that one remember the one was
playing at georgia and they're like oh
your dad was car malone he's like that
ain't my dad
yeah oh this is awkward is there any
live interview on nbc like okay
is there any uh basketball players whose
sons like actually
start doing well stephanie's dale curry
and then also klay thompson oh yeah and
then kenya martin sons a super baller
um shout out to clay thompson for
following me on ig i appreciate it oh
damn big deal yeah no big deal
that's a huge deal yeah i was like whoa
hey okay
um there's some other ones but yeah
there's the ballers
it's what a k got it well you put clay
like the
i don't know he was working out again
he's been
he's been back at him he's so [ __ ]
good dude
he can shoot his his three his like him
and steph curry
because you know how they're like you
know to go pro and support you i come
from the gutters and not from silk
sheets well him and
him and steph curry grew up in silk
sheets and they're so [ __ ] good
but now think of the advantage they had
though like their daddies are
they would warm up with the team since
they were kids shooting balls yeah
getting tips from all the top pros all
the [ __ ] times so then yeah and then
the school
uh everyone everyone talks about how uh
curry put davidson on the map
yeah he was a baller in that [ __ ]
scene 16 yeah yeah and they weren't
[ __ ] how about that no one gave him
like a real offer
davidson was like took a chance on him
and even when he tried to go
even when in the nba i heard they still
weren't really giving him
everyone sold on him he's so good so
good
your boy a [ __ ] booker is good i know
it's been exciting to watch
i think uh cb3 is just was like the
perfect thing
for them uh booker i've tried this
before biggest stick in the league
biggest ding laying in the league how do
you think of that honor
what i mean i'm sure there's some bench
writer has a big old hog
but booker number one biggest
ding-a-ling in comedy
probably rogan bryan has a set of balls
on him too though
we got to set the balls on him brian
some balls and balls
biggest dick in podcasting might be
christian
hey sir got that piece
bang bang [ __ ] 13 got that mic
arm dog
sure key rise up his brother vouched for
him
gianni vouch for him oh really kid got
the dick on hey
bro i look at him differently yeah
what the [ __ ] nothing's dehydrated
because you [ __ ] drank so much over
the weekend yeah
bro all right jim what do you got for us
alrighty
okay so bill cosby is
in talks currently with club promoters
trying to get back it's comedy i mean
there's a lot of people reaching out to
him you think you still sell out
i tell me tell me this chabelle i feel
like the black community is different
than the white community comes this
stuff but also at the same time
him like i mean eight equipment like all
80 are like
all these looks like and they're all the
same story but but but
this is a technicality but think about
the support oj got
you got it's different a lot of a lot of
black comedians
didn't [ __ ] with bill because even
before they he was mean to them
oh he was always mean to him they always
could yeah he would he would chastise
him tell him
tell them about their acts are horrible
and all this stuff so like it goes far
as back as uh eddie murphy and up to
like
even dl hugley you know what i mean like
legends now yeah
exactly so like legends a lot of you
hear a lot of those guys talk about him
and they were just like
yeah he would call and like chastise me
about like my set and like
telling me i'm like you know being
horrible on stage
yeah yeah yeah you know he would be like
how about that guy i got a call from
bill
cosby like he was like like as if he was
their dad telling like what what the
[ __ ] are you doing like like
it's tough case such a beast comics are
you gonna listen like shut the [ __ ] up
no none of them listen
no i mean obviously eddie murphy and
dale shut up
yeah so that that's the only thing with
that i mean i don't know
i'm saying as far as the crowds go
though as far as the crowd do you think
people are going to go to that
yeah i think i feel like i think so i
want to go i kind of want to go just to
see what his jokes are going to be i
mean
i mean you're you're all right we do
check it out it is it is
stupid it is it is a different time in a
weird time
where like i feel like people this is
weird because he got off on a
technicality like obviously he's guilty
of it
but he got off but he said he wanted he
wanted this when he initially got
sentenced
he said he wanted to serve his full
sentence right rather
than admit any uh wrongdoing he refused
to admit to it
so he was just like i was just he was
down he said i'm not gonna for a lesser
plea i'm not
admitting to [ __ ] but he did admit
that that's the reason the technicality
right so he admitted that he did um put
the whatever drug
he did drug those women but he wasn't
supposed to say that at that time
so the prosecution messed up they got
the answer from him before he was
supposed to say
so that was a technicality that's why he
got it that's why i got off everybody
going hard because they're like ain't no
technicalities for uh britney
britney spears [ __ ] ordeal dude
hashtag free brittany
because it all because i mean it's
getting worse and worse do you see her
dad
i guess there's [ __ ] where he's calling
her like a fat [ __ ] and stuff
what and then when he got out of uh out
of the still christians i'm too hard on
that
and then when he got out of the uh how
[ __ ] up is it and then when he got
out of the court he said i am britney
spears like why what
it's a it's a weird thing it's wild cher
came out over the weekend and said that
when she was doing her
residency she was around britney spears
and her people and they were she was
just hearing about how people were
giving her a bunch of drugs to perform
and she was like strung out the entire
time it's just terrible i'm telling you
like
her whole deal was that she had shitty
people in her corner the whole
[ __ ] time that's what she had now
because the court system they still
they're able to control her life even
elon musk put out the hashtag free
brittany
if elon can't free britney who can you
give her money and get her out of it
yeah
but her dad would get that money i like
yeah i don't know what you do
she can't even get like married or
anything she can't get married uh
she legally has to keep a iud in which
is a
form of birth control that they put in
your arm how is that legal at her
age here's like i don't know if we're in
the full story yeah because for a court
to go this extreme
you know what i'm saying to go this
extreme it's pretty hardcore
like we don't we're not hearing the
dad's side there's got to be someone
that has at the same time it doesn't
feel right that
people are making money off of this
conservative no not at all that's the
part where i'm like it can't be right
there's probably something going on
where she's very sick
and she needs somebody to take mental
health but also what's weird is my dad's
like yeah she needs help
i control everything but also [ __ ] give
me 80 percent of whatever you make yeah
also wouldn't it be like if you were her
father looking out for
wouldn't you put that money in like some
sort of savings account and not take
such a high percentage if you yeah if
you
if you actually gave a [ __ ] about her
well-being
she's just a cash imagine if she didn't
have any money no
this would be a [ __ ] problem but it's
all about and then her with her kids
it's like limited she has a limited
visitation she doesn't even have custody
of her kids what's weird so that's a
question
yeah kevin fetterline says that he uh
has full custody and he actually tries
to keep
uh their kids away from her side of the
family specifically
i mean [ __ ] it's i mean so like she gets
visitation rights every now and then but
even that's a little are the kids old
enough to see her like aren't they like
they're like 16 like 17. so they're
still technically
for the court to go that hard in the
paint there's something we're not
hearing though
now i think that dad's a complete piece
of [ __ ] but we're missing some puzzle
this something weird yeah i i don't
think everything's released no
there's something that's [ __ ] so
weird the free brittany hashtag
hashtag free britney oh i bought i
bought a shirt bro this [ __ ]
it was too small yeah handed this one
oh my god what was it besides
[Laughter]
um give it to cat let's
cut it up make it a crop top i don't
know where it said i got to find it oh
yeah
i was so sad does that money go to her
dad or her that's what i need to know no
someone made it
oh just like a random etsy shirt you got
yeah it was absolutely off etsy
it was like one one was like red and all
the other ones were like kind of like
light red you know like
you do those shirts like that yeah like
the to-go uh
bags yeah yeah it was a [ __ ] xl come
on dog
no and xl on etsy is different this is
before i
[ __ ] started before you weighed
yourself yeah did we talk about your
weight on here
when on here the recent one you i mean
you missed friday just me and brian yeah
too
but did you talk about your weight on
the one prior to that teacher
i just i just [ __ ] weighed myself he
he's a brave one he goes he tell
you have a couple i'm so brave you're so
brave i keep my [ __ ] hey
brave hashtag bravery free chef
yeah i just weighed myself i said
chappelle
two well i'd say i put like 270 or
something like that no you were i said
265. no you were nice you you said yes
something like 266 yeah something like
around there you said 260. it was higher
than that here's the thing
here's the thing this one's 277 277 this
is what's going on
but he did hit 330 super easy today can
do three fifty
strong i bet you do 360. here's the
thing you're eating the same
as you were before you're lifting heavy
like we lift like
hardcore heavy weights so you're putting
on muscle and mass
so you're going to be heavier yeah i
think you have muscle but then you also
you're eating like an [ __ ] oh eating
like an [ __ ] i know you're oh you're
back to eating like an [ __ ] yeah
i don't know wearing [ __ ] all the time
with these hands and stuff no
we we eat vegan uh it don't matter
but it would uh we like salads and [ __ ]
but
shut up i don't believe you don't
believe me listen
i love a good breakfast burrito all
right they're the best
yeah there's a lot wrong with my
favorite food i'm 277.
it's heavy man he's heavy
[Applause]
you know he's definitely leaner when he
started working out you're strong as
[ __ ] now but
when i tell you that my that my fitness
pal
if you do the 2000 like twenty five
hundred twenty five hundred calories
yeah i would even go lower but that's
fine
if you go to twenty five okay twenty so
if you're gonna go
25
just track your [ __ ] so you could eat
your breakfast burrito but then the rest
of the day you have to tighten up doug
yeah no i've been following it yeah i
like it a lot it's easy right yeah it's
super easy
i was like oh this is what i needed all
along like like i barbecued all day
nightmare because when you barbecue you
don't have to have fun with the kids
you're just [ __ ] cooking all day so i
barbecued
and i added up the i had a burger and
one brought added everything up
i i fast all the way to lunch and then
by the end
i had some stackies yeah kiddo and then
by the time i got to
dinner i was like oh damn i have 1700
calories to go oh
so that's i went betty honda's but when
you add everything up betty honest adds
up now
yeah because all the fat 1200 calories
what's like everything like this
the rice fried rice then the shrimp but
i still under my calories
what's cool about this my fitness pal it
makes me not want to eat crazy
it like really tastes good look at what
you're actually eating
yeah and i'm like emotionally like if
you have like doritos like now i'll
count them out but
like add up 20 [ __ ] doritos yeah it's
like 370 calories well i mean
what the [ __ ] were people doing before
not i mean just that's right yeah
cause you don't really i mean yeah they
put the calories on on the menu
and [ __ ] but who's really no when you
add up everything
like to add it up and i actually know
what you're doing throughout this makes
it easy because you just type in like
if i have a starbucks like almond
whatever yeah put in there it has the
exact calories carbs sugar so even this
tea
put in you can there's no did you get
honey in there some [ __ ]
no do you have any honey he doesn't have
enough calories
he caught me we got some condiments here
in the studio
you know we do he called me in the
[ __ ] kitchen over there
oh god damn well that's calories there
you go
but it's a little honey it's for that
yeah for the i think honey's natural too
so i like it
yeah oh yeah
what else you got jen uh this here how
many calories do you think you eat a day
chin
oh he probably 1500 no i don't you know
how i say i don't know i don't know but
i eat like one meal
basically one big meal i'll have snacks
like two but good protein snacks
yeah yeah i'm probably 2000
2000 so around 2000 yeah but then i
messed up too i went i eat a lot of good
that's fine what's weird about but like
even though i'm at 277
um i'm able i've been able to wear
shirts that i haven't been able to wear
in a long time yeah again i think you
put on muscle
we still got a ways to go i think you
put on muscles that's what probably
chokes your mouth right now
like you put on muscles so you're bigger
but then you also just you know like
you're bulking you're basically doing
what they call as a bulk phase right now
she gotta tighten it up daddy
you don't need much right cat i never
really uh it really depends on my mood i
think day to day if i'm cooking for
myself i don't eat
that much i'm not really crazy with my
food but if i'm with my sister
and we're out i will eat a grown man
under the table right yeah yeah i can
eat more
nuts yeah especially my sister my sister
can eat enough for three people
like your sister struggle with weight
issues or no uh every now and then yeah
because she and i
like if we're in a funk we tend to eat
like [ __ ]
yeah and then we get a bunch of weight
and then we have to lose it over like
five you're like you haven't been sad in
a while
no not in a while i've been good stevie
yeah that's what i was going to say
stevie yeah stevie doesn't eat like an
[ __ ] yeah he doesn't eat like an
[ __ ] pisses me off the way
right sometimes it's so [ __ ]
frustrating how are you this healthy all
the time
how about you [ __ ] you on your big wake
up making avocado toasted [ __ ]
eating sweet potatoes sweet potatoes
boiled eggs
he takes out the yolk throws it away
just the egg whites
i wish i had that discipline i don't uh
what else you got
so i saw this on rogan's instagram page
and it looks
absolutely [ __ ] fake it looks like a
cgi video
but the uh what is it the gulf of mexico
is in flames right now because a gas
pipeline
ruptured and then a few days later the
caspian
the caspian sea i don't know how to
pronounce it yeah they uh had a eruption
as well and that's on the water in the
water let me see this [ __ ]
so this is the one in mexico lava
it's a fire why water yeah because a
pipeline ruptured
holy hosh and exploded it looks like a
movie that's the oil rig i believe
and there are other clips of boats
coming to
the fire site and trying to put it out
with water
which is such like a weird thing yeah i
see this [ __ ] i don't know
they use like i think nitrogen or
something some
oh that's the worst shirt in the world
that shirt's funny
holy [ __ ] yeah surrounded by water so
how do you
i don't know they probably have
something else in that water trying to
take it out
but i don't see it working that great
jesus christ paige is not loading it's
insane looking
i think it's bloating now there you go
it's so quiet now it's just
this is the casting tee blast
they're saying it's caused by a mud
volcano i don't know exactly what a mud
volcano is
but the clips are [ __ ] is that a
natural one
is that it uh i'm not sure hit that
they're saying that it was an
explosion from that volcano i don't know
if it was naturally erupted or
if something else looks like it's ending
yeah yeah jesus christ
so that's scary um
crazy
oh that one
here we go so this is a big
[Applause]
[Music]
that's terrifying is that what deep blue
sea was about
no no no no those were modified sharks
they put bigger brains than sharks
terribly do
so have you guys been on instagram and
see have been seeing influencers try to
promote crypto stuff
not really so you got to be careful with
that because what a lot of gamers
recently have been doing
is they are getting investments through
these companies trying to promote their
crypto
and they'll sell their crypto to these
influencers
at a discounted rate and once the
influencers then go and promote it to
their following it's usually younger
people with like some money don't know
what they're doing
who don't know what they're doing they
will then inflate the price of it and
those influencers and the people who
own the cryptocurrency then sell it all
and 50 of the coin that they were trying
to sell
from the phase clan ended up basically
plummeting
and they just did a cash dump and it got
so bad that
a bunch of their influencers under this
house or this like fake
phase clan got kicked out and it's all
illegal
and there's one guy in this uh gaming
community
that has been doing this for a while now
and so he's in a lot of legal trouble
because a lot of people are getting into
the crypto space trying to pump and dump
stuff
yeah i mean this is one of the problems
with criminal rights yeah the wild west
so just a psa be very careful if you see
your favorite influencers like promoting
a specific coin
that's the thing it's not necessarily
people who are trying to promote like
coinbase
or like yeah and these are all gamers
so that's a mess
next one speaking of fireworks did you
guys see any of the fireworks
yesterday i heard a little bit i didn't
see i didn't see one fire [ __ ]
so i swear so last week
a man was arrested because somebody
reported him for having a bunch of
illegal fireworks in his home
they ended up sending bomb squad over
there after they found out how much he
had he had i believe
130 000 pounds of explosives in his yard
and then he had 140
homemade fireworks in his home what's he
trying to do
and they were trying to detonate it
because it was so hot that they were
afraid if they
tried to take it from his home and take
it somewhere else to be
uh discarded of that it would explode in
the process so they're trying to
detonate all of them
there i heard the one that exploded in
this truck was only like
10 and pounds of it explosion 17 people
were
injured including including officers oh
my god
it's dynamite man oh this dude in
trouble trouble
oh yeah
[Music]
uh there was a guy in his 20s who went
to nevada and he picked up a bunch of
them brought it back to california
because you can
pay you would pay four times the amount
the original cost
yeah if you got from nevada so they're
just trying to cash in for the weekend
god damn yeah slang in [ __ ] dynamite
that's aggressive that blew it up
entirely yeah okay
let's so selena gomez uh broke the
internet restaurant
yesterday or night yesterday maybe a few
days ago she
uh created a swimwear line with a
company and people just saw what she
looks like now they're like god
damn oh she's such a baddie she's
getting thick and
she is [ __ ] plus
but yeah she was just making her rounds
on the internet everyone's like holy
[ __ ] you look amazing
is that tattoo uh yeah she has a tattoo
she has the like hands
yeah i saw her at the lab factory one
night oh yeah was she pretty in person
she's such a diamond yeah it was we had
an earthquake
uh while that show was going on damn
yeah
i was like selena and i just you tried
saving her yeah
i would save her is it yours or no
uh yeah you still want more from this oh
god damn yeah this one's a shitty one it
happened a few weeks ago but uh recently
it started making rounds again
because it was reported that the school
that
there were two schools involved in a
basketball game one school one and it
was a predominantly white school
they were playing a predominantly uh
spanish school
in california and what happened when the
white school won is somebody
from their team had a bunch of tortillas
and threw it into the crowd
yeah from the from the white team that
juan they threw tortillas into the crowd
someone caught video of this and was
like oh that's racist
you can't do that and they found out
there was some random guy there who
wasn't associated with the team
given tortillas giving tortillas out to
the players
and the players then threw it out the
guy who provided tortillas
seemed like an older guy who was
associated with that school but not
on the team they don't really specify
but he said that
he had no like racist intent with the
tortillas
but he said they were supposed to throw
the tortillas if they won
in celebration but they blew it out
yeah the other team so the high school
got
stripped of the [ __ ] championship but
yeah that's the decision that came
this week they got stripped what the
heck
i believe oh they weren't throwing them
at anyone they threw them into the crowd
and the crowd was like close to the
uh spanish they would have just threw
him up like yeah
that's different if you threw it like
out because you can see i gotta just
throw a bunch of [ __ ]
across that was right there dicey
yeah that was that wasn't great again
did you guys do anything crazy in
football when you're on one
after that never he's kind of poor
gatorade is that still whipping
what pouring gatorade on the coach oh
yeah it still is when you were in a
championship
mark had a funny he sent me this thing
he probably posted on his story post a
million [ __ ] things on the story
everything it turned out nothing got me
more hype than for my high school game
we put on that song
that was me that said there's like
nothing gets more hype when me and my
team would put on i put on for myself i
would hopefully
get beat 70-0
it's so relatable it's the team just
getting all that
from us we about to get
[Laughter]
you know what my uh my high school it
was predominantly latin american too
latinos so one weekend we went back to
school
and then someone threw tortillas spray
painted
all this racist mexican you know against
uh mexicans
stuff it was campus yeah so
we didn't find out who it was but it was
like literally everywhere spray paint
and tortillas
everything what racist stuff are they
saying
what'd they say you know what what'd
they write you know when you're
when you're yeah oh you get so sweaty
yeah they wrote stuff like that yeah
that's a weird derogatory term i know
it's since the term [ __ ] comes from
like them
working and like sweating out in the sun
no it comes from them crossing the
border
uh yeah running away from water right or
water something like that i've heard
different
i heard different ones both yeah
yeah yeah it happens yours makes more
sense
this is just an update on paula costa
remember we were kind of wondering if he
had always
actually had a hair transplant so his
latest videos he's
without any hair this here's not looking
good he's just trying he might be
in the process of healing though yeah so
he definitely did probably yeah he
probably definitely did the transplant
so it's just probably growing out now
but he looks fine bald
right the top coming was bald open yes
what's up he looks funny the top comment
on the other one was bald yeah i think
he just needs to shave it off
yeah i don't know do you think he tried
and that's just
oh no it could just be a self-esteem
thing where he wants him for sure
maybe he looks fine is definitely
struggling yo if i'm going balls
of that old white guy let's see
probably a coach or something or the
hair guy
no it could be the hair guy huh oh that
could be translation portuguese
maybe he's like the the brazilian
president or some [ __ ]
let's see
vietnamese to english why are you
translating venomation
i don't know i'm probably trying to
learn some stuff oh that's really
extremely incompetent
of that there's no doubt look there was
it's gonna be tough
oh it was something political
oh wow okay so not the hair dude no
not the hair not a plug for implants
he's the president of brazil there you
go
alrighty is that it um let me see which
ones i want to show
oh this guy let me just play this real
quick
oh that's the guy who got in his ass
yeah the worst hair of all time
one then your shade you're gonna have
black eyes right here obviously i don't
have black eyes yeah what i'm saying
with you
it's a scratch you scratch my nose yeah
and everyone's acting like i got
like the mall is like i'm like oh
looking like when you were he was
because he had you you know like
yeah how many times did he actually
connect probably like if
you guys it looked like the last one was
the last little one the only one huh
that guy's being real nice to him
there's a fanny pack over his game
[Music]
yeah i don't even know why why would he
why is he doing that why would he i
wouldn't do it
disappear yeah i would completely
disagree about it cut my hair and
disappear yeah
he's trying to parlay this into a career
somehow
i don't know what type of career but it
seems like the only reason why i
met that someone was like hey we want to
do an interview with you well that so
many people did
that with the guy who got beat up yeah
sons of four he's taking like any
interview he can get now oh hard pass
yeah that is 860 likes though
wait i saw something about iggy yeah
this is also
in the news right now i guess she's
accused of black fishing by only
fans and stuff like that so what is that
again what should we tend
to be or like you try to look black is
what black fishing is supposed to be it
looks like a white lady to me
it looks like she had some nose work she
definitely has some words she said in
and then that's her oh
yeah it's just she said it was the
lighting of the video and then she all
she did was change
her wig to a black wig and then people
started accusing
the whole black fishing thing she's good
at her comebacks though
that's why i journal and read i don't
give a f jesus christ
why i mean i don't like your social
media for this reason
too many stupid people on there
and this also every uh every july 4th
i know we're trying to get him on uh
we're trying to get him on here or king
of the stink no way
yep okay he's a california native oh
hey i think but george another
professional eater out of san jose too
his name is matt stone he's huge on
youtube unless you're here why is he
why is that a thing professional eating
yeah this dude i mean i was eating hot
dogs yesterday at chang's channel it's
disgusting watching me because they wet
it right
they wet it and just [ __ ] horrible
there's a japanese dude
he was awesome he was amazing
yeah they had it was like uh i think it
was mtv's true life
yeah remember that mtv it was an
interesting episode too
he's jacked like like lean and jack yeah
he's in shape
in his stomach he put his stomach down
yeah yeah that's why you do it this
white boy beat his ass dog
this guy's been killing that chestnut
[ __ ] night what do you give time
champ doug
what have you 76 hot dogs in 10 minutes
the problem is though i guess the feed
was so bad
so would you catch like a blue screen
then you couldn't see him actually
eating all the hot dogs so that was a
little bit of a controversy oh
but people live katie right that's how i
played yeah people like to see for sure
i put
espn's production plus today on par with
my zoom meetings
this is [ __ ] theirs yeah that's
actually the
actual thing oh come on no i was
watching on my tv i didn't have any
problems really
no maybe i got it it might have been
like a streak well i saw it early he was
at like 10
just [ __ ] deep throating all these
hot dogs and so wait
they have 10 minutes to eat his music
yeah
he always wins he beats like no one yeah
that guy it's great once he beat kobe
he just killed it yeah he's annoying
he's not like out of shape like fatter
he's a big dude though he's just a
regular looking dude though he's not
like
huge enough he's actually pretty big is
he yeah yeah they came but not like
fat fat [ __ ] no just like big dude yeah
also [ __ ] hot dogs but you see this
giant
you see this giant black guy who just
you're like oh he's going to win for
sure he never he doesn't win
he holds like the record on like deviled
eggs devildex
disgusting is it that guy right there
i love deviled eggs actually not that
big six one two twenty nine
normal kobayashi
there's kobayashi five eight one nine
hundred ninety two
what's he up to now i'm killing it why
is tom brady underneath
they looked up goats weird that's what
it is what's kobayashi doing now
um hold on let's see his muscles real
quick
no he's like crazy like rocks
and that's his stomach all like
protruding because of the food
and there he is jacked oh he got that
sauce
ain't talking about soy
got jack sauce
can you still compete if you're watching
oh yeah on stage i don't think he's
gonna help you yeah
right he's bad he's always but this year
why would you i don't know why they were
testing for that
for hot dog eating yeah white dudes
dominating though
yeah anyhow i mean that's pretty much it
man a nice hot you don't like cotton
what do you put on your hot dog
i like relish i like [ __ ] sauerkraut
mustard you like hot dogs love them i
found this
unbelievable place down in uh in north
hollywood called
vicious dogs they're the best hot dogs
i've ever had i had one called
the goomba dog where they put chicken
i'm i'm out it's literally a chicken
parm out of hot dog no i'm out
like your old-fashioned dog dog
this place is like one of my but i like
all the weird [ __ ] like i don't like
there it is you ever had one the mexican
vendors where they wrap bacon
around it yeah like by staples center
not the club but yeah sure
but like no they do do them at the club
yeah they do
any late-night spot yeah this looks
pretty good
it's
that's like chicken with see how far
chicken just give me a [ __ ] hot dog
with the
with the works man relish there's
another place oh [ __ ] hot dogs
yeah you want to [ __ ] your pants eat
that
oh no hard pass no
i can't get that one let's say we had a
hot dog man years you don't [ __ ] with
hot dogs or fake news
big news you're an extremist man that's
what you have right there
uh that's the part that looks like
parmesan it looks like it
that better not be ketchup that makes
you feel sick for this
can you identify it on any of these
pictures here
number four um
i don't think it's on there this just
looks so good that looks so aggressive
yeah there's definitely a lot going on
kelly's in that i mean you have to worry
about that
i'm trying to get as many as i can we'll
eat that stuff i'm eating like 3 000 a
day
dude two of those you're there yeah
no i just like do the works a little
sauerkraut relish onions grilled onions
there's a nice [ __ ] hot mustard next
time you go to the east coast like if
you ever go to a boss or anything it's
kind of a troop
but like you said you like all the like
the onions and everything on it there's
this place in providence called
oni uh oniville wieners they're like
it says winners yeah they're not hot
dogs they're hot wieners
like long wieners the long skinny red
ones around that big
they're literally probably the best hot
dogs i've ever had better than that
place better than anything you do them
three all the way
in hot dogs and staples yup way better
oh wow way better they come with like uh
i don't like shredded beef on it uh
ketchup mustard and onions
all it's you don't have to get it like
shredded beef dude
damn you're a picky eater huh the
regular american hot dog for god's sake
this place is unbelievable though
you keep trying to add all this [ __ ] to
it you i like brats
you like brats a big thick bra yeah
things are mouthful now
don't those look fire though good
because they're not that big yeah yeah
they look nice
that does look nice that one is like one
you like hot dogs
of course man i love them you like hot
dogs cat
yeah i usually like um hot links though
oh i love hot links i like a big
thick over cooked brat like it's all
crispy
mm-hmm what's the difference between a
broth and a hot dog
broth's like a sausage it's like pork
and it's like thick
you can get like spicy it's like gray
too right usually a grayish color
is that it oh you know what they're pork
you should i think
they're thick man keep saying thick i
know
y'all going in about some [ __ ] hot
dogs y'all and chappelle's disgusting
yeah
too dude get that chicken hot dog in my
[ __ ] face dude
if you're gonna do it do it all right
brats are less violent but you're all
literally [ __ ] hot
hot dogs are skinnier brats are thicker
yeah no [ __ ]
is that a chin i think that's it all
right kids
hope this made you want to go get a hot
dog uh this saturday first
calabasas fight campaign going down with
josh thompson
uh cody garbrandt myself and bradley
martin you can watch it
live on the thick boy youtube page ufc
264
calabasas fight companion this saturday
live
first sets in la are happening next
weekend friday saturday
two show saturday july 16th two shows
saturday july 17th
at the haha we haven't shopped in a
minute
since pandavas yeah these are my first
sets in l.a uh the haha in
l.a july 16th 17th job and friends of
some funny ass friends with me
then july 29th through 31st tacoma
washington
right outside seattle there uh las vegas
got postponed they didn't get a permit
so they
postponed the grand opening so that's
fun uh good thing i already got my
airbnb there yay uh rallied north
carolina
august 19th 21st september 9th through
the 11th san jose improv
september 24th 25th is the big boy san
antonio bud light
event center the courtyard outside att
arena there
san antonio stand up promo code for
pre-sale tickets is
thick then denver's on there honolulu
tickets at thickboy.com or fatkz.com
baltimore staying the [ __ ] up that's
next weekend that's
next weekend you're going to miss my
date man uh what is your oh yeah you're
doing the shopping friends
uh well baltimore uh july
15th through the 17th magooby's joke
house and then
uh are you coming to hang out in bray or
no
what is it do i have shows then where is
that
i think you do la jolla i think it might
be
like ah no it might be
go to anyways august me [ __ ] is 2016
that one that has the old dates yeah i
think
let me refresh you yeah you'll be in la
jolla yeah
yeah 27th you're 26 though
you're doing a sunday yep we're doing
uh friday saturday sunday and then uh
we're probably if we attribute what we
would go with thursday yeah man why
won't you come there
you better perform there it's the best
clubs in the country all right hey
step your game up you would i was going
to feed you a hot dog no you're not
going to feed me a [ __ ] house
that's not my [ __ ] 25 100. we didn't
make it fit in there no
let me see you swallow broad dog [ __ ]
you
let me see swallow why you want to look
let me see you and mark swallow brian oh
let me see you in mark's show abroad
mark don't swallow that [ __ ]
just [ __ ] all sick yeah
uh is that a chin that's it all right